one of the most brilliant men we know
Adam chap nick is with us today we're
very honored to speak with him Adam tell
us what you do what do i do I spread the
gospel about crowdfunding at IndieGoGo
the world's largest open international
funding platform check it out was
awesome whoo you know I the first thing
we want to ask you Adam is we just
launched our campaign for goodbye
promise on IndieGoGo four days ago and
um you know it was a you know a little
bit I don't know those trepidation you
know leading up leading up to this
release you know there was something
anxiety yeah we haven't seen anyone do
this before us as far as we know and so
I want to ask you from your end did you
ever see something like this coming I
mean on the one hand no and on the other
hand yes you know total props ups kudos
to you guys for seeing a way to
distribute a film that nobody's figured
out and nobody's tried it's now that
you're doing it I'm sure everybody's
saying oh my god why didn't I think
about that is such an obvious idea what
a great way of the future it's you know
like all good ideas the things that
everybody feels like they should have
thought it um but having said that you
know it's just the first time in film
that someone's doing this right because
really what you're doing it's it's no
different from I mean it's not if it
from delivering a product from
delivering an e-book to from delivering
you know any other kind of music
downloads that happen in similar ways
across the internet maybe not exactly
the way you're doing it but it's so fits
the temperament of the of today's like
internet consumer that I I can't say
it's a total shock you know it's it's a
logical continuation of what's happening
everywhere which is why it's such a good
idea well it's funny because people have
said that to us where they're like oh
wow either I wish I had thought of that
or you know I kind of was thinking that
would be a good thing so
is this the first time anyone's brought
this type of a style of distribution up
to you is this is this um yes Brandon
really well Oh David when when David
told me about the idea I was like am I
ever thought of doing that myself and I
had to say no and I had to think as
anybody else you know brought this I
don't know it's like I said it's such a
it's one it so it has the hallmark of a
good idea where you kick yourself when
you hear you're like that is too obvious
that I didn't think of that and that's
great so no one to my knowledge nobody's
done with you cuz I know when he brought
up to me I was nervous about it and and
and you had very definite ideas and I
said okay and then we talked it over
with Gregor Collins who's the lead actor
and also one of the producers on the
film and we agreed and David you felt
the most strongly about it and so we
kind of just followed your your path but
it seems like people are really
resonating with it and also because this
is the first time that anyone has done
this so that being said you think this
will be possibly a new wing of indy gogo
in terms of it's hard to say I mean yeah
I mean we'll see I think it's it's the
kind of thing that I would be surprised
more people don't try it for sure you
know but like everything it's gonna take
a while to figure out the best way to do
anything new you know and I'm interested
to see what people think of including
you I mean because you guys obviously
have a good coconut apiece well I mean I
mean to be honest I made it you know
we're four days in you know certainly
what we're pretty excited with what
we've been able to do so far because
here we are we're offering the movie
essentially for one dollar you know that
that's the sort of the going
contribution we've been very surprised
by some of the results early on we're
already after four days approaching a
thousand dollars you know hopefully
we'll hit that very soon in the next few
hours so that's pretty amazing in itself
there you know beyond that you know some
of the numbers we've seen so far as
we're asking for the dollar the average
contribution was closer to eight dollars
you know / contribution that's great you
know so you know all the numbers and all
that kind of stuff favorite I think I
think it kind of lends itself to the
power of transparency you know I think
you know there's so much that's really
what's kind of going through our heads
today is just the transparency factor
you know especially with digital
distribution no no one knows anything
you know you see so many filmmakers that
we talked to her just like you know what
are the numbers everyone wants to know
the numbers and it is it is great to see
that the audience you know so far you
know the I mean we don't know where this
is going you know we won't we only have
like 120 people that have jumped on so
far so it's very tiny yeah but but they
seem to be excited and then they seem to
be getting behind it and sharing it so
that's that's pretty neat stuff that's
happening so far um you know that's
great i mean i think it's it's like like
everything you know when you try
something for the first time using you
know a one kind of platform to do
something else sometimes there's pain
when you're that first person because a
lot of people take a long time to even
wrap their head around what the world
you're doing because and especially you
know being in the vanguard of a new way
of using something that's in the
vanguard itself or it most people don't
understand crowdfunding you're already
like around the bend the next iteration
of crowdfunding I mean there's there's
pain associated with being a visionary I
mean we saw I didn t go go I mean there
was four of us you know whatever two and
a half three years ago working for
nothing in our houses you know like
hoping people would understand what the
hell we were talking about and there was
pain because we got it and it was just
people didn't understand what the heck
we were talking about eventually that
comes around now with what you're doing
I see it clearly you know my background
at de stripper I was all about thinking
around like what's another way to get a
film the you know from a filmmakers hand
without going through all of the baloney
that you have to go through to get into
an audience's experience how can you do
this in a way that meets people where
they are and isn't expensive and you
know is just sort of workable and this
could be a way
but the the you know maybe the
challenging news is that it takes you
know their take some education for
people to understand the methodology and
that can take and so there's when
it's your film and you're counting the
money you know that can be painful or
nerve action yeah sure sure I think too
it remains to be seen that you know with
a filmmaker an artist that has a bigger
audience I mean we have a very small
film in a very small audience and and
there's no big names attached to it so I
think if you got somebody else like
Kevin Smith it could really be tested
I'm wondering just from our short time
with you on the on the skype here and
you had just a moment to glance at it
anything stick out to you in terms of
what maybe we're missing in terms of our
message or what we're doing that looks
great let's look okay yeah like it are
we yes let's go uh-uh so one thing I
mean this is this doesn't speak to the
efficacy of what you're doing but one
thing I would typically counsel against
is having a goal of a million-dollar
only because if for no other reason then
if you don't hit it you pay IndieGoGo
more than you have to I mean why pay I'm
not taking from me I mean it's you know
I work it at yoga but I that's one thing
i would say that give yourself a chance
to pay less that's less of an exciting
tip but something i noticed is going
from the top down um the the other thing
something you did great here is you have
a lot of logos at the top of your
explanation with blurbs from your
reviews and that's great for creating
some social proof and making people feel
like you're legitimate i think that's
awesome you've got you know stills in
this in the description with link outs
to the people it's all great and
statistically we know that those things
create a larger revenue for a campaign
all of those things you just did but i
just described on it um you know you've
got bonuses that you offer which is
great moving down or more stills is
great there's a statistic on indiegogo
that i'm not going to be able to
recreate the exact numbers but the the
more images and media that you put in
your campaign than one money your
campaign will make its it's not quite a
one-to-one correlation but it's a
general correlation so that's all drinks
um one thing I would wonder aloud I
don't know the answer but i was wonder
about is you chose to have the only
thing you offer be the film and that's
in some ways quite interesting because
it's putting a stake in the ground that
we are distributed and we're not you
know crowd funding but having said that
some of the most successful campaigns in
crowdfunding our distribution campaigns
not necessarily of film or whatever but
across all platforms whether it's us
kickstarter anybody else you know you
see widgets that are sold but what
happens is on a lot of those campaigns
they often have a lot of high-dollar
contributors who either by a lot of
something or a special edition of
something or some more involved
participation in what you're doing and
while on the one hand i think it's kind
of cool that you're keeping it clean as
a distribution method the fact that
you're what we'll call your perch and
what you're offering are all you know
tiny dollar amount and don't give
anybody an opportunity to do what I call
unlocking the value of the creative
process meaning all of the people who
are enamored of moviemaking but who may
be decided to be a dentist or a lawyer
and didn't want to go through all the
misery of becoming a filmmaker just so
they can have that day where ya at the
end I have a film but what they have is
money and they'd be willing to trade
money for the experience
being a filmmaker like coming to set or
just you know engaging in subway
whatever it is maybe it's even you Phil
might be long in the can but engaging
with you as filmmakers in the process to
feel like they're a part of it those are
things that we know high-dollar
contributors like to involve themselves
in and it often has no cost to you so
there might be an opportunity here for
you to add perks where people can get
involved in certain ways you know
because I don't know your your circles I
don't know your your network social
network or audience whatever whether
those kinds of people exist in large
numbers or small numbers but regardless
when crowdfunding works it's your
message reaching through your network
and into their networks and often that's
where those dentists and you know
lawyers or whatever who think would be
cool there's something to do with a
movie that's a thought yeah absolutely
you know and then certainly something
that that's gone through our heads I
guess I guess at least for me talking
about it you know we have crowdfunded
before we've crowdfunded on that that
other platform I don't Sam just I'd say
Kickstarter no kidding I'm just kidding
no but we did we did crowd funding on
kickstarter and one of the things is you
know we had a bunch of perks and and i
guess just from our side we just want to
make it easy not just for for anyone
that wants to watch the film you know
because we have the film where it's like
you know you contribute the one or two
dollars and then it's available in the
update section so it's there so we just
wanted to make it easy for for the
viewer as well as ross we just don't
want to be tied up with any sort of like
promises any additional time it's just
like we just want to keep it simple on
our end especially we don't know how we
don't know how many people were going to
reach and we don't want to be in a spot
where we have to fulfill however many
hundreds or thousands of rewards that's
really gonna you know absorb our time so
that's kind of in our boss in our cost
as well so we just want to keep it super
simple but but totally other would
totally binding what you're saying as
well so it's just it's just this this
positioning what we're making here with
that yeah like I said there's an
elegance to the fact that you're staking
your territory as a distributed as a
distribution play I mean I think there's
something to that that's that's an
exciting story in fact this is true I
was having lunch today and the guys I
was having lunch with said oh did you
hear about these guys that are now
distributing through indiegogo as is
there i don't be talking to them in 70
minutes very cool oh really it's like i
said how did you ask them how did you
hear about that and they said oh i read
it on something on the internet called
like no film school like all right Ryan
there you go it works tech night yeah
yeah we look back there you know cool
you know what were you you know via
Kukui had to be in the first one we turn
we turn to Adam you know I ended up
being the first one we had a chance to
speak with and and you know we just have
such tremendous respect for what he does
with no film school and its really so
great to talk to you because because of
what you do do with distribute you know
finding that company you know because
ideally you know where we still had the
sugar in mine you know we're really care
to see what happens here in indy gogo
but we still have this platform on work
we're still not sure what's going to
happen but what you have filmmakers in
mind in that sense and then you also
have this position with IndieGoGo where
you kind of head up sort of like film
the film department with IndieGoGo you
know distribution and I guess a lot of
our frustration is just we have this
small film and it's like you know we
sort of have to fight into the system
that exists it's like even with the
stripper like there's no guarantee that
you get on iTunes there's no guarantee
you get on hulu there's just don't
guarantee that you're going to be able
to access the audience that you're
trying to get to you know when you apply
to film festivals there's no there's no
there's no guarantee that you'll get it
to the film festivals you know
theatrical distribution my feeling is
that's really not a game for smaller
films that don't have the money and
resources you know so you know we were
just looking at it we just like we just
want to take our little movie and we
just want to just just easily get
the people you know what I without the
hassle without like the obstacles and
and and really the way we view it we
believe at this point in time it's not
but it's not the perfect platform but we
believe IndieGoGo is as close as we
could find you know we started looking
at some of the things we wanted to do we
believe IndieGoGo is the best
distribution platform not for all films
and certainly um not not not for
everything but fur but for smaller films
that maybe you know are going to have
that tougher time fitting into the
system you know so here we are and here
we are talking to you play I think it's
brilliant i mean i do i think it's it's
a really great use of a platform that
can reach people in a viral way it's got
video as one of its core presentation
elements and as you pointed out it's
imperfect the way it is with the updates
and that they are inherently open and
there was some trepidation about them
being open and what not great
observation and i think this is the kind
of thing that to me it's exciting to see
what the conversation is going to be
around this as much as you know of
course i want you to have a million
dollars in 20 days i want that to happen
you know proposal us right but I mean I
think it's really to your credit that
you're thinking outside of the box this
way you're thinking this way is how
IndieGoGo got started right it's how the
streamer going to start it's exactly the
way you're thinking is the way we were
thinking in one way or you know that
we've got a lucky bats you're lucky
bounce there a book where we all are so
it's entirely possible that if the
conversation takes fire around this I
mean I could see you know the community
making the case for feature set being
added things like that where it becomes
I don't know in what ways yet right
maybe none of us do but in certain ways
where it does become a distribution
platform I have an intention not like
because some smart guy and someone
figured this up you know that's I think
I think it's a great story obviously
that you came up with this you know well
yeah yeah i mean really at the heart of
it is just you know i mean there's
there's so many
factors that go into it but as mentioned
it's just you know we have a really
small film and and we just we just want
to get in front of people so that's
really the heart of it yeah and it cost
so little to make and and and you know
probably much more in post-production
but why incur all the costs of festivals
and all that and you know deliverables
and everything we can just kind of do
this and maybe recoup some of the money
back or or or or actually break even or
maybe even make a profit so yeah I think
it's a perfect way listen yeah I think I
mean are you guys out reaching and I'm
sure you are but in you know to the
community in terms of blogs with the
sort of the hook that this is a new way
of distributing and then let's get into
a conversation about how this might look
and are we on to something and that kind
of stuff that's that's a very
interesting like I was saying
conversation that I think can come out
of this I mean and then you know beyond
that in your updates on the site there's
another interesting step that updates do
correlate directly to funding so the
more you update the more money you make
which is sort of counterintuitive
because updates go to people who've
already given you money but what happens
maybe I'm preaching to the choir but you
know what happens is the people who have
kind of started supporting you as they
see your updates they start to feel
proud of what they're supporting and
they start to share more and when and as
we know it's the sharing that makes the
viral event happen and the more the
virality happens the later in the
campaign the more strangers come when
your when your success bar is higher and
higher and this is another reason why
it's tricky to have our super high goal
because there's a psychology stat that
we've noticed that first that strangers
tend not to jump in until between twenty
and forty percent of a funding gold
regardless of its size so at a million
that means like two to four hundred
thousand dollars
so I realize that you know we're not
about them right so but but even
forgetting the percentage I mean you
know keeping updates coming and talking
about you know the successes that are
happening whether it's in the dollars or
in the word of mouth and then also I
think maybe adding perks there's a
statistic about perks that are added in
campaigns that sixty-three percent of
successful campaigns on IndieGoGo have
added a perk after lunch which is two
thirds yeah that surprised me I didn't I
wasn't aware that people are doing that
in that fun but I know that you are
talking about how you were trying to
keep costs and pain in the ass down and
I totally respect that but and you know
having the pleasure or the opportunity
to see see you speak in Santa Monica we
also felt like okay let's just start
with two and if something come emerges
that you know that wouldn't be a pain
for us to add as a park that maybe is
more of a premium Park you know knowing
then let's hold that back just in case
so it's it's really just sort of diving
into the water and kind of swimming
around a little bit and see what happens
you know I love it yeah oh and just real
quick Adam do you think we should add
more photos to our campaign page i'm all
about it i know dave wanted more of a
cleaner look I tend to like things more
extreme so um well they're statistically
the more if you have 10 or more pieces
of media that's you have the most
benefit from your meat okay so that's
the stats talking yeah whether they're
in your campaign page or in your gallery
I'm not sure where the steps measure
that if it comes like on the front page
or in your gallery you have technically
three in your gallery and maybe could
you do one two three four five on your
page so I don't know whether we should
whether it means your gallery knock it
over ten is a good number ok can I can
ask you about the updates because you
know hopefully like I said hopefully
we're gonna go over a thousand dollars
very soon and I certainly want to use
that as a benchmark to let me take this
opportunity to personally guarantee that
you will go over a thousand dollars in
the next several minutes so I can take
your credit card while we're okay it's
hard for me to talk your during
interview while is awesome okay i'm
going to buy many downloads right now
but that's kennedy believes in the dream
baby believes in a dream that's it I do
you know wow this is cool okay yeah I
see we can take a moment and then we can
share any pause this yeah we can really
cool thank you that's awesome huh thanks
please that's really awesome so um that
we can continue I can do this I'm our
next one more test um so with the
updates I you know obviously we haven't
done a lot we've only done two so far
and and you know we understand the power
of the updates and Davey babies because
I only I've only done two and maybe
because um yeah maybe because I've only
done two but it's a little frustrating
so far because you know we have to have
the film in the update section and we
want that to be the first thing and
right so but we also want to add photos
and we want to ask videos and you know
we want to have we want to have more
stuff there and I'm kind of stuck I
can't really is that is that right you
can only have one media and the update I
don't believe that's true actually uh
now you might have stumped the band on
this interview right there I have to
look into that I think you can have more
than one media in an update but if you
know that you can't you might be ahead
of me that's possible yeah you know yeah
really because I want to use the power
of the update that I just we just
haven't been able to tap into that yet
and I don't know is it somehow tied into
the gallery you're talking about like do
you do you store media in the gallery
and then you're able to pull it to the
update no I don't think that's I mean if
I just did not honestly I need to get
that granularly conversant with my
platform to know about whether i could
have to media in the update the same
time I thought you could but we can
certainly look into it um you know as
far as how to make that I think it's
important to keep updating but that is
interesting that you've kind of
pioneered this way of using the update
page and you don't want to have send
people there and have them have to
scroll down and not be able to find the
actual length yeah I wonder I was gonna
just say keep posting it up in every
update you know like here it is again
yeah you know no here we have it we're
gonna have it every update but then I
won't go to add another like if we have
a screenshot of being on script magazine
like being on tour or being on no film
school like you know you want to have
you know you want to be able to add some
visual flair to each update you know
that's what i would find out for sure
but i believe you could have multiple
multiple media and your updates and if
you can't you let me know and i'm going
to do something about that i find that
would really be able I don't know if I
have to do it in time um okay my public
comment on my contribution will be film
courage is the best oh thank you are
true pioneers and we at IndieGoGo are
proud of you and that you are blazing
your trail with us that's great thank
you that's awesome you know I give me
goosebumps early in love it's true I
will not narrate my credit card number
thanks cool um so yeah you know that's
awesome that's really awesome you know I
you know we know you have a lot of
things to get to you know just just
lastly just any any additional like
thoughts or advice in terms of s we just
crossed a thousand dollars you know what
are some things we need to keep in mind
what are some things we need to keep
doing in order to continue to spread
word here and continue to grow
you know for me to be talking to film
courage pair of that spreading word is
maybe a little bit silly you should be
telling me about how to do that because
people love hearing what you had to say
and so all I would say is you know in my
short but wonderful relationship with
you one thing that I have noticed your
total credit and is your humility and I
think that's one of the likeable things
about you absolutely but don't
underestimate the esteem that the film
community hold you in and I think you
can reach out to people and you've been
providing a lot of benefit and a lot of
great content to all of us for a long
time and I think all of us are very
eager to give it back so don't think
that we aren't and don't think that by
asking you are imposing because I think
everybody would be eager to give back to
you in a way that you guys have been
giving to us for such a long time that's
the tip I'm that's great I don't have
near the best underworld I was nice oh
thank you like we're just going to thank
you thank you and boom it let you get
back to what you're doing and we're
going to get back together doing is
contributing to the screen can't hang on
to go go that ice heard it's called
contribute to 30 days to 1 million
worldwide release at the back rumps join
me and contribute I'm apartment number